I served in the Air Force for four years
everyone at my hair like this since I
was a little girl and when I joined the
military it was just a no-go I served in
the Army for six years I served in the
United States Air Force for four years I
served in the Air Force for six years
and I could tell that the regulations
weren't necessarily written by people
who had knowledge of black hair and how
it worked
I served in the United States Air Force
for 23 years I decided to go natural by
locking my hair the vet is awesome and
she ligase my founder the military has
requirements and how they can where they
hear it used to be that women cannot
wear locks in the military now there are
in regulation as such a freedom excreta
[Music]
I've been working with women in the
military for nearly thirty years about
95 percent of my clientele is active
duty or retired military you have a lot
of strong women in the military they
want to concentrate on protecting the
United States and not because of
training on whether or not if they here
is in regulation the Coast Guard changed
the regulations about four years ago the
army followed like a year ago in the Air
Force about six months ago with this new
change now African American women can
feel good and also look correct in their
uniforms
I've been in the Air Force for two years
I was so excited about the change but I
felt like locks were how I was gonna be
able to express myself and show people
who I am
[Music]
how are you doing today
you're ready for me hey when the young
recruits come in is very important to me
that they feel safe and comfortable and
I have to really learn what was allowed
and what wasn't allowed when people are
not in regulations they get in really
big trouble with their commanding
officers so we have to make sure that
they stay in regulation after I finished
my teas hair and she turned around and
looked in the mirror I can just sit at
her eyes she was so happy my hair really
doesn't define how well I can perform my
job but in a lot of ways it Hans's my
personality because it is allowing me to
be myself you can't serve if you're not
able to be yourself I love putting on my
uniform every day I hope Covington the
United States Air Force with my heart
with my locs not I feel complete in my
uniform but I carry the new regulations
in my wallet just in case anyone
approaches me about my hair no one has
because the vet keeps me good
[Music]
you
[Music]